- I'm not a bigot,
but, calling me a racist is true.
I'm a racist, damn right I'm a racist.
And I don't hide that.
I'm a racist person, but I'm not a bigot.
I don't hate anybody, but I'm a racist.
A racist is somebody that loves their race
and love their people.
- [Interviewer] All right, Steven.
Steven, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Steven] I grew up in
New Albany, Mississippi.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
You had both of your
parents growing up as a kid?
- My dad wasn't really
in my life that much.
My dad was a Vietnam veteran.
He had a lot of health issues.
He wasn't in my life a lot.
I think I got, my dad got in my life
when I was about 16 years old.
And my mother practically raised me
and my brother herself.
And you know, so I had a mother
that was a very strong religious woman
that raised me and my brother, so.
I had a good childhood, I can't complain.
I had a stern mother that taught me
to be an honest person and a good person.
So, you know, I had a decent
childhood, I really did.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- I was a loner, I stayed to myself.
I still to this day I can't
tolerate certain people.
I just can't, and it's
not really a racial issue.
It's just, I can't be
around a bunch of people,
I just don't like being around them.
- [Interviewer] Was there
racism in your family?
- I grew up, when I grew up
at a time when the riots
in LA was going on.
I'd be watching TV and stuff like that,
and you'd see when they
pulled that old boy
out of that truck in LA, you
know, the Rodney King stuff.
And I grew up in a very racial time.
So I grew up in a time
where this stuff was not
being forced down me,
but maybe at the time, I shouldn't
have seen that as a child
but this was something that I seen a lot.
You know, it wasn't hidden from me.
Racial stuff was not hidden from me.
So yes, it was a part of my life.
It was a part of my childhood.
I was Mississippi
burning when I was a kid,
I always looked up to the Ku Klux Klan.
I always admired the Ku Klux Klan.
I always said that I'd be
a great leader one day,
I always said that.
- [Interviewer] Did you have relatives
that were in the Klan?
- My grandfather was a very racial person
but I'm not gonna say he
was a Ku Klux Klan member.
But no, I mean, the Klan thing
is something that I took on my own.
It's something that I knew as a child
that I'd do this, this is my calling.
This has always been my calling.
- [Interviewer] So you're
the Imperial Wizard.
- I'm an Imperial Wizard.
That's the highest rank as
far as the Ku Klux Klan, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And Mississippi, is one of
the strongest states for the Klan?
- It is, the Mississippi White Knights
is one of the most respected groups,
as far as the Ku Klux Klan goes.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- We have the most respect.
I had left the Mississippi
White Knights for a little bit
and (indistinct) started North
Mississippi White Knights.
But now we're gonna bring it back.
We're gonna get everything situated again
and get the (indistinct) in order,
and start everything back over again.
So, I've just kind of just moved
back from Portland, Oregon.
So I've got to-
- [Interviewer] You were
in Portland for a while?
- I was a little bit there.
- [Interviewer] Is it very different?
- Four years, it's very different,
but I did love it, I love the weather.
I love the beauty and there's
a lot of white people there,
but they're liberal
minded, they have no idea.
I was married to a girl, a Norwegian girl,
and her family was very liberal
in mindset and judgmental people.
They judged me for being in the the Klan.
I'm no longer married to her,
but at the time that
was the love of my life.
And it didn't work out.
It just didn't work out
because people are judgmental.
They're too judgmental about
everything you do in your life.
And at the end of the day,
they need to look under their doorstep
and sweep and see what they've
got going on in their life.
Most people that judge me for
being in the Ku Klux Klan,
and hate me for being in the Ku Klux Klan,
there's an underlining reason for that.
They're gay, they're homosexual,
they're a race mixer.
No, something like that.
But I don't judge anybody.
I give anybody a chance,
but if you wanna judge me and say,
"Hey, this is, that wrong
for the Ku Klux Klan,"
then I'm gonna judge you,
'cause you're giving me
an open door to judge you.
So I'm not really a judgemental person.
I don't force my beliefs on anybody
until they wanna judge me, so.
- [Interviewer] Interesting.
So the South is notorious for racism.
There's a long history
of slavery, segregation,
all kinds of all kinds of
issues that you guys get-
- The poverty thing is that
we have like I said, I
lived in Washington state,
I lived in Portland, Oregon,
and we have a lot more freedoms here
than I did up there.
So there's positive and negatives
about the state of Mississippi,
but I love the state of
Mississippi as my home.
I love it, there's great things
about the state of
Mississippi, and I love it.
The blacks tend to wanna
have a reason to bitch.
Sorry about my language.
They wanna have a reason to gripe,
they wanna have a reason to throw a fit,
they wanna have a reason to tear shit up.
And that's where the
Ku Klux Klan comes in,
to put a stop to it and say,
"It's not gonna happen."
You know, I've had corrupt cops
in the city of Tupelo, lose their job
because Ku Klux Klan was involved
because we wasn't gonna have it.
We wasn't gonna have it.
I stood up for my people
in the city of Tupelo,
and inside of Mississippi.
But blacks blame it on us so, they do.
They sound like this officer
that got shot in Atlanta.
I mean, the officer that
shot that guy in Atlanta,
took his taser, man.
But people don't understand
if you read "The Turner Diaries,"
it plainly says it that,
"If you get the law, that
is the last line of defense
between us and communism.
If you get rid of law enforcement,
if you get rid of law enforcement,
then that gives them,
communist an open door
to come in and take over."
And I got a 19 year old daughter,
and that era, her age, around that age,
is gonna be the worst, the worst.
I don't know what this
country is gonna become
because they're freeloaders.
They don't wanna work, all
they wanna do is smoke dope.
They don't wanna work.
They don't wanna do right.
And I try to instill that in my daughter.
And I try to tell my daughter,
"You know that is gonna be
the worst generation ever."
My generation was slacking
on a lot of things,
but that era, that generation
is gonna be, we're fucked.
I mean, this country is fucked.
But that's where the Ku
Klux Klan is gonna come in
and say, "We're not gonna have it."
"We're not gonna have it,
we're not gonna put up with it."
- [Interviewer] What is the
basic idea behind the Klan?
Is it not just as simple as racism, right?
- My belief and my goal
for the Ku Klux Klan
is it is a racial thing,
because you gotta be white
to be in the Ku Klux Klan.
But my goal for the Ku Klux Klan
is to protect this country
from all out invasion,
from anything, from any type of thing.
The goal of the Ku Klux Klan
is for the advancement of the white rice.
I'm not a bigot, but
I'm a white separatist.
I'm not a white supremacist.
I don't consider my race superior,
but we have to have organizations
like the Ku Klux Klan,
to instill the children
and the people that wanna join
to teach them that
there's a greater cause.
There's a greater call.
Being a Klansman is one of the
greatest things in the world.
I mean, I love it.
I wouldn't take anything for it.
And man might judge, I don't give a shit.
That's one thing about me,
I don't care what anybody says about me.
You can judge me, you can say
anything you want about me.
It doesn't affect me 'cause the minute
that a person takes time out of their day
to judge me and say, "I'm
wrong or I'm this and that,"
that means I've got to
them, I've affected them.
'Cause I don't give a shit what
anybody else does, I don't.
But the minute that they take time.
It's like when people come to my rallies,
and they make them signs
up and all this shit.
You took time out of your
day to go make a sign,
go by that marker, go
by that poster board,
I affected you, I have won.
It an accomplishment for me.
So, you know.
- [Interviewer] So separatism
is a big part of the Klan?
- I think that the only
way that the white race
will ever survive is we separate.
And I'm not saying that
we get rid of the blacks.
I'm saying that, give the
blacks just like the Indians
give them their own homeland,
give them where they need to go,
give them just as much
rights as a white man does.
But you put the biggest
wall up like Donald Trump
built on the Southern border.
Where it's separated, you're separate.
The whites and blacks are separated.
That's the only way we're gonna survive.
- [Interviewer] And so
does the same thing apply
to gays and Mexican?
- It's gonna be odd for me to say this,
but love is a hell of a thing.
And it's gonna be really
odd for me to say this,
but love sees no color in some ways.
It's weird for me to say
that, but it's the truth.
Love does not see a color,
but you gotta love somebody.
But it doesn't mean if you
get with a black person,
you sell out your race.
You act black and you sell out your race.
You love a person not for their color,
but for who they are as an individual.
That's the reason I
say love sees no color.
And that took me a while
to get to that point.
I guess living in Portland taught me that.
But you know, I've experienced it.
If you get out of the state of Mississippi
and you go other places
and you experience things
you find that love is,
love is an odd thing.
It's an odd thing.
It's worse than any drug
you can have in your life.
That's what I'm saying, I
married the love of my life.
And I'm still in love with her,
but it's over and done with,
but you don't see a color when
it comes to love, you don't.
But you still need to
have love for your race.
You need to have love for your people,
and is race mixing wrong?
Race mixing is exactly wrong.
You stay with your people.
- [Interviewer] Your ex-wife was white?
- She was white, oh yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, definitely.
- Just making sure.
- [Interviewer] Are you religious?
- [Steven] I'm a Baptist.
- [Interviewer] But the Klan
is a Christian organization?
- [Steven] Yeah, we're Christian,
that's what we're about.
I consider us like that,
and I said it before,
like the Taliban or Al Qaeda.
I do consider us that we're
technically the same thing.
Just like they are hot
fighting I said before,
(indistinct) we're fighting a Holy War
for Christianity, for our
race and for our people.
That's what we're fighting for.
Have I done anything illegal? No.
Have I been to prison? No.
I've never been to prison,
but I will always stand up for my race.
And if it was ever a point
to where I ever had to go to prison
for doing the right thing
and standing up for my race I'd do it.
- [Interviewer] Do you guys
still have rallies and-
- [Steven] Oh, definitely,
definitely, yeah.
I just had one Russellville, Alabama,
cross lightings, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And
there are still hangings
of black men in Mississippi?
I've seen news.
- [Steven] I don't think
that's Klan related.
- [Interviewer] It's not Klan related?
- [Steven] No, I would know that
that if it was Klan related.
I'm telling you for a
fact, if that happened,
if a Klan went out and hung a black man
in the state of Mississippi,
I'd be the first one to know that.
- [Interviewer] Well, you're
the head of the organization,
so you'd know.
- [Steven] I'm a leader,
Brother Richard is my Leader,
but I'm an Imperial Wizard,
Brother Richard's an Imperial Wizard,
but right now Brother Richard is the man
that taught me everything I know.
- [Interviewer] So the Klan is smaller now
than it was when you were younger, right?
- No, no, when I was younger,
there wasn't any much Klan around,
but now, there's so many
underground Klansman
because, I don't know.
It's like a lot of people
when Donald Trump got elected,
they think the white
supremacists are just rampant.
They think the white
supremacists are just rampant,
and it's not true.
We have stopped.
Like I said, I lived in
Washington state, Portland,
and I come back home and it's amazing me
how nobody's doing nothing.
Stand tall for what you believe in,
fight for this shit, and get it.
Now I'm home, and we're gonna
straight Mississippi out.
- [Interviewer] Did having a
black president for eight years
affect you in any way?
- The thing is about Barack Obama
is a lot of people said that,
"Barack Obama was a bit
worse than Jimmy Carter."
I don't care who the president
is, that doesn't affect me.
I'm not a Donald Trump really supporter.
I do support some of the
shit that Donald Trump does
but Donald Trump also
says a lot of dumb shit.
If he'd keep his mouth shut,
he'd be in a lot better shape.
And that's the truth.
But I have, I love the president.
I love Donald Trump.
Wasn't a fan of Obama.
Wasn't a fan of a Bush.
But in anything, it's like
the Klan was more awake
when Obama was in there,
now that Trump's in there
it's like we've quit, and
that's not gonna happen.
I'm gonna be the gasoline and the match
that's on the fire to light this back up,
and I'm gonna light it
back up, and I can do it.
And I'm telling you gasoline
we gonna pour some gasoline
on this like this shit.
And light this son of a bitch up,
and it's gonna be wide open.
- [Interviewer] So do you see whites
as superior to other races?
- No, I'm not, I never said that.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not-
- [Interviewer] No, that's fine.
- No, no, no. I'm not a white supremacist.
I'm not, I don't consider my white race
superior to anybody,
but we do have a lot of accomplishments
that is left out.
That we've done a lot of great things.
I'm a white separatist.
I believe that we should be separated
but I don't consider the white
race superior to anybody.
I believe that the white race is
the most beautiful thing in the world.
It's like, do you really want me
talking about my ex-wife?
- [Interviewer] It's up to you.
I mean, we're not gonna mention her name.
- Okay, so I don't see how somebody,
there I'm gonna tell you something
about the beauty of the white race.
Somebody can be Norwegian.
My ex-wife was from Norwegian ancestry.
How you can be a Norwegian,
how you can be anything European,
and then sell your race out
and not be proud of your race.
The Norwegian people are
some of the most beautiful.
It's a beauty, it's beautiful women.
I mean, the woman that I
was married to was amazing.
That was my trophy wife,
I guess you could say.
And, but how can you be.
I'm English ancestry.
But how can you be German
or anything like that?
I consider that, it's all the white race
but that is a superior.
You wanna talk about superiority.
Norwegian, anything like that,
that is the superiority of the white race.
But how can you not be proud of that?
If you want to talk
about something superior
that is superior, that ancestry.
Like I said, I'm English ancestry.
I'm Howard, all my
people call from England.
So, and most people in the South are that,
you know, they're English ancestry, so.
But how can you be pure,
I'll call it pure Aryan race
and not be proud of that,
and not stand up for that.
It amazes me how that
happens, it amazes me.
I don't like race traitors,
I don't like rice mixers,
because that's killing out the white race.
Now, like I said, I'm
not a white supremacist.
I'm a white separatist.
I believe that whites and
blacks should be separated.
I don't believe in race mixing.
I believe that race mixers
are the worst part that
are ruining the white race.
I've had a black woman tell me
that she will never be with a black man
because the way the black men are.
This is coming out of
a black woman's mouth.
A black woman that I knew,
everybody's got mammy or whatever.
Here's a black woman that
practically raised me as a child,
that babysitted me as a
child, like a mammy, you know?
And that woman would tell me to this day
she's an older woman,
tell me till this day,
she'd never be with a black man.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How do you feel about
the "Black Lives Matter" movement?
- The movement itself?
I don't know much about it.
I'm gonna be honest with you.
I can't wrap my whole
mind around what that is.
I can't, is that a political organization?
Is it a black supremacists organization?
They have a right to be proud to be black
but Black Lives Matter,
to me they're a black
supremacy organization.
And that's why you need
organizations like the
Ku Klux Klan to say,
"We're not gonna have that,
we're gonna stop that."
(indistinct) Black Lives
Matter in Tupelo before, yeah.
- [Interviewer] How do you view
what the Klan has done
for you and your life?
- The Klan, when I was a young child,
like I said, I looked
up to the Ku Klux Klan.
I always wanted to be a Klansman,
but the Klan has bettered
me as an individual.
I have people that come
up to me and be like,
"Man, I know who you are.
You're the local celebrity around here."
And I'm called, literally
people I've worked with,
or people that I know call
me the local celebrity.
I don't consider myself a celebrity.
I don't consider myself
better than anybody.
I put my breeches on just
like anybody else does.
Anything that I've done
in the Ku Klux Klan,
I try to tell these other guys,
"Stand up, take charge."
Like I said, "Put the
gasoline, put the match,
light this motherfucker up,
and let's go, let's do it."
And the Klan has always,
has bettered me financially.
If I needed anything, food, my kids,
anything, the Klan has
always been there for me.
It's made me a better individual.
It's put something that I'm proud to be,
something that I can look up to myself.
So, they can say what
they want to about me
but I've always tried to do
the better thing for my race,
for my country, and the
Mississippi White Knights.
And I'll continue to do that.
That Klan is,
if anybody wants to be a Klansman,
anybody wants to be a Klansman,
take that chance in life, do it,
because you won't regret it.
Is it hard at times?
Will it cost you relationships?
Yeah, but if a woman
won't stand behind you
for the she'll say, "Wooh,
I'm not gonna be with you
if you're in the Klan," then
you don't need her anyway.
She's looking for a reason.
They need to accept you.
That's what women need to understand.
That if you wanna love,
women, the white women,
have now turned into something
that it blows my mind, it blows my mind.
The beauty of the white
race, they'll sell it out.
They'll settle down with a nigga.
They'll sett;e down with a Mexican.
I didn't mean to say that.
They'll settle down,
they'll do anything,
but they won't give
the white man a chance.
And it blows my mind.
And, if a woman wants a real good man
and a respectable man she
needs to look for a Klansman,
'cause a Klansman's gonna stand tall
for what he believes in.
I'm not a coward, I don't cover my face.
I will never cover.
When I joined this organization
I joined this organization to be a leader,
to take charge, to be a
role model for other men.
So I will never hide my face
'cause the Klan is the greatest thing
that has ever come in my life.
And I do not regret it,
I love it, I love it.
- [Interviewer] So it's
Juneteenth this weekend,
will you be celebrating?
- No, I'm definitely not, no.
- [Interviewer] No rallies, no-
- That's the strange thing about that.
I don't know much about that holiday.
I know it's free the slaves or whatever
but I believe that
when we brought them over
here, we bettered that race.
If they think they've
got it so bad over here
take your ass back to Africa.
I will gladly pay for a boat trip,
for a boatload of them motherfuckers
and take them back
there, I will pay for it.
I will rent the boat and
pay for that son of bitches,
if they don't like it in this country.
Gladly pay the ticket.
I will pay the ticket.
I mean, I will set up a PayPal account,
send them blacks back to Africa, donate.
I'll put them on a cruise ship.
I'm gonna have fun while
they're going back to Africa.
They won't like it,
and they'll come their
ass back over here, yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right, Steven.
Thank you for talking with
me and sharing your views.
Some very interesting stuff, thank you.
- There you go.
- [Interviewer] Thank you man.
- [Steven] All right, yeah.